life moves pretty fast if you don't stop
and look around once in a while that you
could miss it
well Ferris Bueller's Day Off moves
pretty fast too perhaps everyone has
seen it so many times that they didn't
even stop and look around and realize
that there are a lot of baffling events
in the movie one of Faris's earliest
schemes involves securing a car for the
day
Ferris tells us I asked for a car I got
a computer as a way of explaining why he
doesn't have wheels of his own the
problem is that his computer is one of
the many expensive toys that fill his
bedroom in addition to a computer cool
enough to be connected to the web in the
mid-80s Faris's room is also stuffed
with a slick sound system and even a
synthesizer he puts two particularly
good use throw in a classic electric
guitar and he's got quite a bit of money
laying around sell your stuff Bueller
after fooling his parents with a fake
illness Faris's next big task is
convincing his best friend Cameron fry
to join him on his day off ironically
Cameron is already out of school for the
day home sick in bed for real Ferris
doesn't believe Cameron noting his
hypochondriac tendencies but Cameron
does seem to be quite ill so much so
that he barely feels like moving somehow
Ferris is able to rouse him and bring
him along on the trip and just like that
Cameron is fine he goes from lying in
bed to hanging out at a Chicago Cubs
game not once during the day do we see
Cameron becoming dizzy trying to nap
bored knocking back some day quo he was
either faking it or he was miraculously
cured Ferris invites Cameron along in
part because he needs a car they could
just use Cameron's but Ferris is too
greedy for that he wants to spend the
day out on the town in style and has his
heart set on stealing Cameron's father's
car a limited edition 1961 Ferrari
convertible it's a pretty sweet ride and
so valuable that Cameron's dad doesn't
even drive it he just rubbed it with a
diaper
despite the car's value though there's
little to no security for it it's just
sitting there without any protection in
the garage which Cameron and Ferris can
just walk into it's almost as if mr. fry
wants it to get stolen
Ferriss covers his tracks at his house
with a dummy a complex pulley system and
a tape playing snoring sounds by
comparison his scheme to get his
girlfriend Sloane Peterson out of school
for the day
is surprisingly low-tech it starts with
a phone call from Cameron hosing his
Sloane's father claiming her grandmother
died Faris and Cameron then head to the
school to grab Sloane
when Ferris arrives he has to disguise
himself as her father by wearing an
oversized trench coat and old fashioned
hat somehow Dean of Students mr. Rooney
is fooled by the lazy ruse even after
Ferris and Sloane share a long wet kiss
one of the first things Ferris does on
his day off is take Cameron and Sloane
to an extremely fancy restaurant he
doesn't have a reservation so he steal
someone else's from the restaurants list
for this scheme he chooses to pose as
Abe Frohman the sausage king of Chicago
the restaurants host is of course very
skeptical of Ferris has claimed Ferris
works around him by having Sloane call
the restaurant and described him as
Froman somehow it works and the
baby-faced teen who is obviously not a
meat magnate gets his table one of the
most famous scenes in Ferris Bueller's
Day Off is the parade sequence but
there's a lot about the scene that's
hard to understand it's a big cultural
event that shuts down several downtown
city blocks but it's somehow held in the
middle of a weekday the heart of the
scene is a bit baffling two huge parades
are highly secured but this one just let
some random teen up onto a float to
lip-synch to an old Wayne Newton song
and why does the float have a microphone
anyway it's not hooked up to any kind of
sound system this all leads to a
synchronized dance number set to twist
and shout it's a little more realistic
that Ferris would know that song but
it's not realistic at all that a bunch
of people have put together dance
routines to go along with this otherwise
completely spontaneous performance
Ferris plans his day off so it's packed
with extremely fun activities he and his
friends go to the Sears Tower the Art
Institute of Chicago a fancy lunch but
Chicago Cubs game and even a parade one
problem with packing all that into one
day is that there's no way Ferris
Cameron and Sloan could fit it all in
with the limited time they've got it's
mid-morning by the time Ferris convinces
Cameron to come with them then he has to
jailbreak Sloan from school and then
drive into the city once they're in the
city they have to leave the car in a
garage
factoring in travel time between
activities plus setbacks
traffic there's no way Faris is getting
back to the suburbs before his parents
the villain of the film is Dean of
Students Edie Rooney and he both hates
and obsesses over Ferris Bueller the
thing is that Rooney actually has a good
reason noting that Ferris he gives good
kids bad ideas
it's Rooney's job to keep the student
body in line and in class something
Ferris doesn't help with he has so many
absences that it's a problem
Rooney knows this and even sees the
evidence of Ferris covering his tracks
by hacking school records so Rooney
spends the movie tracking Bueller to
prove the kid isn't really sick he goes
through a lot of nonsense to catch
Bueller in the act of skipping school
which means he's really just a guy
trying to do his job check out one of
our newest videos right here Plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]